[Música]
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony blinken visitó las zonas
afectadas por el terremoto en Turquía al
tiempo que anunció un apoyo por 100
millones de dólares de Washington para
Los afectados en suelo Turco y también
Siri
el presidente de Chile Gabriel borich
calificó a su homólogo nicaragüense
Daniel Ortega de dictador el mandatario
chileno es el único de la región en
condenar de manera vehemente la
persecución a la oposición
Río de Janeiro vive un carnaval especial
sin restricciones por primera vez en dos
años hoy conoceremos más de la historia
del sambódromo de esta ciudad inaugurado
en 1984 y con capacidad para 75 mil
personas
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes de América y del
mundo soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y es
un gusto acompañarlos tras participar en
la conferencia de seguridad de Munich en
Alemania el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinquen visitó
el este de Turquía devastado por el
terremoto del 6 de febrero en conjunto
con el noroeste de Siria el jefe de la
diplomacia estadounidense anunció la
concesión de 100 millones de dólares de
ayuda suplementaria a Los afectados por
la catástrofe
acompañado por el ministro de asuntos
exteriores Turco el secretario de estado
estadounidense Anthony blinken llegó a
la base aérea de incierlich aquí donde
se está entregando parte de la ayuda
humanitaria para las víctimas del
terremoto del 6 de febrero todavía
marcado por las imágenes de destrucción
en la provincia de atay que acaba de
sobrevolar el jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense vino a mostrar el apoyo
de su país
cuando es la magnitud de los daños el
número de edificios el número de pisos
el número de hogares que han sido
destruidos para ser necesario un
esfuerzo masivo para reconstruir y
estamos comprometidos a apoyar ese
esfuerzo vamos a Añadir 100 millones de
dólares para ayudar a quienes lo
necesitan desesperadamente
una ayuda que se suma a los ocho cinco
millones de dólares y a los helicópteros
enviados por los Estados Unidos para
entregar alimentos y suministros de
Socorro a las víctimas
del 6 de febrero también se han
desplegado 200 socorristas
estadounidenses para ayudar a encontrar
supervivientes pero casi dos semanas
después de la catástrofe Turquía ha
anunciado que dejará de Buscar excepto
en las provincias más afectadas de atay
y caramanás un anuncio que alimentará
desesperación de quienes aún no han
encontrado a sus familiares
mi primo sigue bajo los escombros la
búsqueda debe continuar para encontrar
al menos su cuerpo
este terremoto es la peor catástrofe
para la Turquía contemporánea solo en
este país han muerto más de 40.000
personas y cientos de miles quedaron
damnificados
el presidente de Chile Gabriel borich se
pronunció en contra del despojo de la
nacionalidad a 94 personas nicaragüenses
por parte del régimen autocrático de
Daniel Ortega el comunicado del
mandatario resalta en la región
latinoamericana en donde los líderes
políticos de los principales países han
tenido posturas menos contundentes sobre
las nuevas medidas de Ortega Manuel acá
no tiene los detalles
un comunicado que contrasta Gabriel
boric se pronunció de manera categórica
en contra del despojo de la nacionalidad
de 94 nicaragüenses por parte del
régimen autocrático de Daniel Ortega un
abrazo fraterno a Gioconda Sergio Sofía
Carlos y a todos quienes Ortega ha
pretendido despojarlos de su
nacionalidad nicaragüense no sabe el
dictador que la patria se lleva en el
corazón y en los actos y no se priva por
decreto no están solos
el mensaje dista de los pronunciamientos
de los mandatarios de la región
latinoamericana que han sido mucho menos
terminantes según señaló Guillermo
holmesmann analista político para France
24 este responde un enfoque de Derechos
Humanos propio de borich que marca su
política exterior
eso lo lleva por ejemplo a plantear de
que Venezuela eso dio la cédula de hecho
humanos lo propio también en Nicaragua
por supuesto también en Cuba y el de
goriche resalta de comunicados como el
mucho más Homero el Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores expresa su
preocupación por la decisión de retirar
también la nacionalidad nicaragüense a
otros 94 ciudadanos Brasil y Argentina
por ejemplo Siguen sin pronunciarse la
postura de la región está muy marcada
por visión ideológica y expectativas
ideologías que se han ofrecido la
población lo que hoy día ha hecho
Gabriel boriche colocar un punto de
inflexión y progresivo de América Latina
en términos de coherencia y política
particularmente y que debiera llevar
probablemente a un debate y si es que no
a un cambio de posición las medidas
tomadas por Ortega se enmarcan en una
nueva ley proclamada que regula la
pérdida de nacionalidad nicaragüense un
paso más hacia la persecución política a
la oposición en el país centroamericano
el presidente de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador firmó el sábado el decreto
con el que se nacionaliza el litio esa
nación es la décima con más reservas del
mineral Y ahora será la secretaría de
energía la encargada de manejarlo
mediante una nueva empresa llamada litio
para México previamente conversamos con
Santiago Arroyo experto en y consultora
especializado en petrolíferos que nos
dijo que impacto tendrá que ahora el
estado maneje litio
Bueno pues de entrada viene una serie de
impactos negativos sobre todo obstáculos
al comercio en dos de los capítulos
bueno en capítulos de obstáculos al
comercio precisamente de dos de los
grandes tratados de libre comercio que
se tienen aquí en México firmados con el
exterior que es la alianza transpacífico
y también con el famoso tratado América
del Norte es decir con Estados Unidos y
Canadá teniendo en consideración que
Canadá y China Perdón en Estados Unidos
y China son dos de los países que tienen
las mejores tecnologías y son uno de los
mayores
digamos inversionistas y desarrolladores
de tecnología para la explotación de
litio Entonces esto viene a cerrar de
manera tajante estas cuestiones y muy
probablemente vaya a considerarse
también como una especie de afrenta a
estos tratados internacionales y a los
intereses también de estos países
y en Chile la nadadora Bárbara Hernández
rompió el récord mundial como la primera
persona que consiguió nadar dos coma
cinco kilómetros en aguas del Océano
Antártico el 5 de febrero Hernández no
perdió la conciencia en ningún momento a
pesar de salir del agua con una
temperatura corporal de 27 grados
Celsius
con solo un traje de baño un gorro
lentes y protección para los oídos
Bárbara Hernández hizo historia al
convertirse en la primera persona en
nadar dos kilómetros y medio en aguas
del Océano Antártico y el corazón lo
sentía al lado no se sentía que de rato
pasaba como algo helado que no es la
piel es como adentro
y es que a cada brazada quedaba
Hernández estaba un poco más cerca de
sufrir una hipotermia que puede provocar
una parada cardíaca y finalmente la
muerte pero ella no se detuvo hasta
alcanzar la boya que marcaba que había
logrado su meta en ese mar gélido apenas
dos grados Celsius
[Música]
fue un out súper difícil duro porque
es un lado muy largo entonces antes de
completar la primera milla como que
sentía que no llevábamos nunca a la boya
y voy muy concentrada como en la técnica
en el pateo obvio que siento los brazos
cada vez más pesados porque la sangre se
empieza a golpear o sea lo que hace el
cuerpo es deja de la sangre deja de
circular a manos y pies cuando la podada
sirena del hielo salió del agua le
tuvieron que sacar toda la ropa para
abrigarla llegó a la enfermería con una
temperatura corporal de 27 grados algo
que muchas personas no habrían podido
soportar y que le ha abierto la puerta
el reconocimiento de la asociación de
natación internacional de invierno y
también al récord guinness que se espera
que le concedan por esta marca ahora su
próximo destino es Nueva Zelanda para
asistir a la competición Seven Ocean
vamos a Río de Janeiro que vive un
carnaval sin restricciones tras dos años
y hoy vamos a hablar del sambódromo del
Marqués de zapocaí fue inaugurado en
1984 y tiene capacidad para 75.000
personas Valeria sacona corresponsal de
France 24 en Brasil nos amplió los
detalles
hoy empieza en el sambodromo la
competición más importante del carnaval
dos escuelas de samba aspiran al título
de campeón seis se presentan esta noche
y aquí en el bextello al lado del
sambódromo es donde se preparan las
escuelas porque cada una tiene hasta
3.200 miembros y hay que formarlos en
alas para que puedan salir a la hora
exacta en el lugar correcto
es normal está todo el mundo corriendo
en los barracones entregando los
disfraces cosiendo cosas que se soltaron
arreglando cosas siempre hay un poco de
atraso Pero al final todo sale bien
gracias a Dios
imperio Serrano es una de las escuelas
más tradicionales del carnaval de Río de
Janeiro ya fue campeona nueve veces del
grupo especial pasó muchos años en una
situación difícil sin dinero este año
está volviendo al grupo de élite del
carnaval Y tenemos mucha fe en que vamos
a quedarnos aquí es nuestro lugar
es más que cultural es algo que
transfiere a nuestros ancestros en
realidad heredamos esta fiesta de ellos
y nosotros solo la estamos perpetuando
a categorías como los disfraces la
canción la obra como un todo porque un
desfile en el sambódromo es como una
ópera itinerante que se puede ver en 360
grados entonces cada detalle importa
viendo el informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]